live I forgot to put something on the
back TV I don't so a whole bunch of crap
back there this is a crap it's camera
I'm not talking I'm fine oh the junk
yeah
Ethan yes get to it snappy snappy nice
ass this is a quality stream we're here
for quality entertainment so welcome
welcome to undertale again continuation
of it I like the the bouncing twerk
across them get that camera - it's just
so distracting for Tyler here and can
you turn that TV on to something
appropriate it's no oh okay if you
manage to turn that on and turn this one
off okay you're good great
I wanted Ellen on my stream like 25%
special guest Ellen on the show here
thanks for being on here she's the
headless Ellen it could be anybody but
as well oh yeah you absolutely wouldn't
know so
they're good job oh no what is happening
this is now available what are you doing
you're on the wrong thing brotherbrother
road other remote
that's even better so everybody hadith
and why hi there we go cameras over
there hide yourself yeah he hasn't
properly been trained I'm using two
remotes yet that's understandable though
he needs to figure it out right quick
ready we know we weren't we're sorry
we're not sorry at all to be fair I will
take the blame because I was busy over
the other locations trying to make it a
secret obscure place it's a yeah were
you gonna try to subterfuge laundry I
was trying to do some it's okay you
don't need to be that secretive alright
over at the house yeah that there we go
so anyway welcome to the stream don't
mind that back there yeah I just leave
it like that
that's good if you look up porn a
ten-hour loop of pen bone okay all right
fine go for a picture but if that pulls
up any party very best in you all right
anyway so that that's all besides the
point we're not here for that we're here
for undertale this what is that what the
heck is that what happened I don't know
oh that's cuz it's the other one caboose
key there we go I got it hang on huh
wait now I got to readjust all this
everybody bear with me reset it all
right anyway
we yeah yeah all right this is our
professional item does everybody love it
it's great Freddie's best guess scooch
closer together can people stop banging
out there
not literally banging this lady yeah
they're just banging going on like a
hammer yeah hammer so bad we did stud
straight over it's going awful actually
it's going just about as quality as all
of my streams normally go so I guess I'm
sure this is highly entertaining for
everyone so why
TMZ up there I turn around what are you
doing I'm trying my best
why don't you just look up landscapes no
no just pick Ken bone you're already
there yeah you're already in the bone
zone to stick with boner all right
you realize you don't have to use the
arrows you can put your finger on there
and point the remote why is it not
working yeah
all right anyway you know what we'll let
him figure that out I on behalf of
everybody here apologize for the intern
that's what you've been to me anyway
that season is easier by the way over
say nine even hotter
hi are you ready to get back into P Bo's
journey pop up there for sales well okay
all right then
all right so hopefully everything's good
and the audio isn't all kerfuffle cuz
someone hasn't been checking yeah
can you let us know if things are good
to hear buddy thanks again you're the
best anyway okay so welcome back dunder
tail that was the pre-show hope you
enjoyed it totally intentional wink all
right so we are back in the quiet area
so let's take it down a little bit
this is all back into the game here
we're gonna recap what we just went
through we just got done with the fight
with Undine and it well it did all
things considered even though I died a
few times it went well it was an
interesting fight considering that she
wanted to kill us and then we had no
capability of fighting back know what I
mean we just had to run away we had to
run away repeatedly which kind of is
like an idea this is a child right
I think so I mean so we weren't there
like mixed thoughts at the beginning
like it was like preteen or to kid I
mean I have no idea honestly it's very
ambiguous like what that character model
is it I think it's intentionally
supposed to be the most like blase type
of sprite you could possibly imagine so
no one really has any idea of like boy
girl doesn't matter supposed to be a
blank slate but like even I don't know
why I'm committing to the parting my
hair wrong way to Sonic it up here for a
little bit here anyway so like it's
fully a different like it doesn't matter
who it is so it's people its people yeah
it's a massive people so either way
we're done with the fight with Undine
and I have a new keyboard here that has
bigger keys so I actually won't be
screwed up all the time
and we're gonna go to undines house yeah
because it's the sands called us almost
there you're almost correct our let's
review sands is the short one
papyrus it's only been less than a week
dude alright so papyrus invited us out
to a party which we're finally ready to
go a hole for human orion's are you
ready to hang out with
I have a plan to make you two great
friends ready I am ready okay so you're
the social butterfly here so you guide
me through this
okay stand behind me make sure to give
her this she loves these I don't know if
she wants fire did you see someone
already made fan art that I am who'd you
bet I am
you beyond I know beater bars and I
brought a friend I don't think
awkward pauses why don't you come in
here Ondine my friend brought a gift for
you on their own okay that's fine don't
worry we'll just pick it up with your
normal voice I think we've had enough
with only four extreme events will I
pick up undines real voice alright
alright sees a bone so are we ready to
start I have to go to the bathroom you
two have fun to rub your victory in my
face oh boy humiliate me even further is
that it yes all right mr. social
butterfly I mean that's how you know
them but I want to rub the victory in
their face we didn't exactly like if we
could have killed her yeah pretty much
so I mean I would rub the victory in
their face hundred percent
but that's not how you make friends do I
wanna make friends I don't know what
she's got a pretty beastly suit of armor
all right okay no then why are you here
wait I get it do you think that I'm
gonna be friends with you no this one's
especially sweet all right yeah sure
I mean why not I mean I don't I would
never assume that especially after such
a rough introduction uh-huh but I also
wouldn't say never I wish there's a
middle office well I mean I bet a lot of
people in this game wish there was a
middle uh like like I'd like to try it
would be the option I would choose since
so sincere all right fine yeah I guess a
lot of sarcasm oh wow okay Wow Wow oh
she is sarcastic no fields a friend
that's sarcasm
not
why would I ever be friends with you if
you weren't my houseguest beat you up
you're the enemy of everyone's hopes and
dreams I know never be your friend along
stream to get through believe it or not
we're only 15 minutes in oh hi
dang what a shame I thought unban could
be friends with you but I guess I
overestimated her she's just not up to
the challenge
papyrus wait a second
darn it he thinks I can't be friends
with you
there we go BAM
I'll show him sure listen up human we're
not just gonna be friends we're gonna be
I'll make you like me so much why don't
you have a seat compose a kazoo take a
seat oh oh all righty then
well this sick of Church Island play the
piano all righty then one time Alfie's
friend came over all he did was lie
seductive
and fed himself grapes I don't really
like that guy but I admire his life see
alrighty then so everyone wants us to do
sundown is that what we're getting from
this sit-down and progress no not yet
geez yeah human sack with their history
kind of case in point this giant suit
humans wielding swords up to ten times
their size I don't know if that's true
yeah we totally did
hundred percent bruh my swords tenth I
first heard that I immediately wanted
so me and alphas build a giant sword
together she figured out all the specs
herself she's smart see I I hate cold
food so alphas fixed my fridge so it
heats up food and standards
Hut fridge the world's greatest sandwich
there's a silverware drawer and as forks
spoons knives tiny swords axes Spears
nunchucks okay
top-of-the-line MTT empty it you're not
wearing your gloves rust okay but you
know as much as technology advances
nothing beats food home-cooked with fire
magic in the sink is a teacup in the
shape of the fish okey-dokey then
can I go in your bedroom you wanna see
my room she likes the smart one I used
to be an engineer
all right let's progress yeah yeah let's
do the thing comfortable no I'll get you
something I'm not comfortable I'm
literally standing on the stool this
doesn't seem to be helping my posture
it's gonna be hot God what is that what
why all set what would you like
red is the thief oh hey don't get up
you're the guest
sit down and enjoy yourself damn it okay
why not just point to it okay you can
use the spear can i all righty then
oh geez okay so there's the sugar goes
in tea soda sickly al illiquid some
Mountain Dew hot chocolate green tea box
correct choice when I'm gaming hell yeah
I want some Mountain Dew you it's true
dorita hooks they're not sponsored no
get those out of there all right hey
wait hold on some sweet sickly yellow
liquid boo boo ski soda actually even
though he pointed to it you don't look
happy that's fine
I think so does gross - it rots your
teeth it rots your mind
watch your fighting spirit
why do I have it
okay then sugar that suitors for the tea
oh sure I'm not gonna give you a human
ice-cream woman
Tara's humanity with energy spheres are
there ice cream song Zee prelude to
destruction video did I don't think I
put meat route to that challenge it was
this video oh there was an ice cream
truck going through a neighborhood and
it was just faded way in the distance
and you could barely hear him and as it
gets closer and closer you just start
hearing Hitler's speech
- put it there though like probably
shouldn't let's keep this I spirited
anyway that's totally off topic sorry
everybody that was the question
oh did she look like some terrorizing Oh
ice cream oh yes what really that rules
Oh see it's like no matter what you
choose ah yes the green hot chocolate oh
you want some hot Chow putting the hair
back though it feels wrong on my head
keep going keep going
wait wait I just remembered that
containers empty I stopped getting it
because it was always a hassle asgore
kept getting marshmallow stuck in his
beer so as Bora and as the basis can I
get oh fridge yes the fridge you want to
have the entire fridge yeah no believe
me I would gladly give you your face
it's nice if you weren't my beloved
house gasps nice okay well can I can you
point to her yeah put it her hey you
want to drink your perfection
are you hitting on me
hell yeah hell yeah I am hell yeah whoa
oh you're not gonna stop me I'm
persistent
how about the sugar you know sweetie
there's nothing else I can pick why the
tea is it poisoned yeah that's why she
wanted to stab you with your sword it'll
take a moment for the water to boy get
off thought I could move the sphere like
was gonna get it okay it's all done
oh no she's using she's gonna use all of
it here we are
don't trust this I don't trust this
little careful it's hot how can I hear
man voice all right anyway don't mind
that a wild boar just bolted its way
into this office and it had my face on
it and my voice it was the craziest
thing it's testicles hit together it
sounded like personal
I'm glad you're so anyway
Tyler's top ten rules to manliness if
you want to be the manliest man when you
run clap your balls together and make
the sound of my voice
you'll be the manliest man get all the
ladies and or men if you want that or
anything
maybe boars okay whatever you know what
forget it go it's not that hot just
drink it already you take a sip of the
tea it's burning but other than that
it's pretty good it's pretty good right
apparently that's what the descriptions
as for my absolutely precious friend my
voice crap
congratulations hey you know it's kind
of strange you chose that tea is it
golden flower tea Oh were you drinking
flowey god I hope not
tries to throw seeds at us no that's a
scores favorite actually now that I
think of it you kind of remind me of him
in what way
what a mask or TV no wait no that's
there we were both total weenies nice
sort of okay awkward alright I was a
pretty hot head of kid wants to prove I
was the strongest I tried to fight on a
school emphasis on track
I couldn't land a single blow on and
worse the whole time he refused to fight
back I was so humiliated
afterwards he apologized and said
something goofy excuse me do you want to
know how to be I said yes and from then
on he trained me one day during practice
I finally knocked him down
I felt that but he was beaming I had
never seen someone more proud to get
their butt kicked
anyway long story short he kept training
and now I'm the head of the Royal Guard
well fancy that and you lost to a child
so what good are you
what good are you I'm damned this mask
is driven well good are you so I'm the
one who gets to train dorks to fly good
all right then like papyrus this is
where papyrus comes bashing through the
window to be honest I don't know if I
can ever let papyrus into the Royal
Guard don't tell him I said that he's
just well I mean it's not that he's weak
he's actually pretty freakin tough it's
just that he's he's too innocent and
nice I mean he was supposed to capture
you and he ended up being friends with
you instead I could never send him into
battle he'd get ripped into little
smiling shreds that's part of why I
started teaching him how to cook you
know so maybe he can do something else
with his life that's so sweet
I was like really sweet sorry I was
talking for so long you're out of tea
all right I'll get you some more and I
would have felt terrible if I killed the
virus wait a second
papyrus his cooking lesson
he was supposed to have it you have to
have it that's right nothing I closer
than means that if I give you his lesson
but for now so we add the new where's it
all stored in the ceiling
Oh mein noodles are the best I just buy
store brand alright now it's time to
stir as a general rule of thumb moister
the better it is ready let's do
so hard all right now for the final step
turn out the my passion burns real your
hopes and dreams turn into my leg around
I hope some day
ready
fine oh man no wonder papyrus sucks okay
so it's nice
scrapbooking friendship presents Oh Who
am I kidding
I really screwed this up didn't I I
can't force you to like me human some
people just don't get along with each
other I was having a great time I don't
know what she's talking about
I understand if you feel that way about
me we can't be friends that's okay dude
because if we're not friends
it means I can destroy you without
regret that's a little extreme there
that's oh did it escalate to this okay I
even failed to befriend you
Max's need you here if I kissed anymore
once
oh I'm a caramel watch on both sides
it's the only way I can regain mellow
spread I mean my patch kind of fish like
yes
teach me with all you've got Wow undyne
is letting me make the first attack this
time George hold anything back
show me what you've come on okay you
make the first attack a fake attack
that's dumb and you're dumped thinking
that's not dumb you're you're a dummy
I'm gonna do your worst
Chili's effulgent attack here we go we
pretend to swing and then dangle tell
you mate oh yes you best you can manage
even attacking it fool Horace you just
can't much here in the attempt anything
you know what and I'd actually want to
hurt you either at first I hated your
stupid saccharine stick but the way you
hit me right now it provided me of
someone I used to train with it was so
pathetically bad I remember I was
training a baby at one time and it pawed
at me that's what that reminded me of
now I know you aren't stiff some wimpy
user your wimpy loser with a big heart
just like him who your squad nor your
scorned lost lover that's war listen
human it seems that you and özgür are
fated to fight but knowing him he
probably doesn't want to talk to him I'm
sure you can persuade him to let you go
home eventually some mean human will
fall down here
and I'll take their soul instead that
makes sense right
and if you do her tasks I'll take the
human souls cross the barrier and beat
the hell out of you that's what friends
are for right
now let's get the hell out of this
flaming house the house in the inferno
it was a little toasty well that was fun
huh we'll have to hang out another time
but somewhere else I guess in the
meantime I guess I'll go hang with
papyrus oh so if you need me
drop by Snowden oh and if you ever need
help just give papyrus a ring okay Oh
since we're in the same spot I'll be
able to talk to oh well see you later
Punk oh I shipped papyrus and Undine
poop Undine no under s nope nope under
iris open drivers happened Drive
happened dry ice richard dreyfuss
that's their ship name is Richard
Dreyfuss and that's what I'm going for
all the houses crying oh it's dying
somebody help it oh gosh that's
horrifying why is it dying I don't need
this do I look angry angry crying okay
here sounds like the only fire lives
here now all right you could finally get
to take a break of your voice yes what
well a spot it's a living what you don't
have anything to say about the burning
house alrighty then off we go
those nice feeling calming tranquility
so how do we get back to Snowden is
there like a fast transport it would be
a long walk I don't know yeah I don't
think there was anything any fast waited
well they had talked about tunnels but I
thought that was in maybe maybe if we go
for wait but that's not even forward
that wouldn't lead for that led to oh no
wait that did magma magma magma mumu so
we could go forward to magma mumu or
maybe we could go backwards to snow
water well this is where that Oh
what if he remembers so if we go forward
because I haven't seen one so there must
be something on the way back all right
there on the way forward because
otherwise it wouldn't make any sense
having to walk all the way back would be
super obtrusive this is yeah that's okay
though hopefully maybe they're not gonna
attack us now maybe they're gonna be
super chill and cool and you know be
totally hip inhabiting dope peeps that
are gonna leave us alone and not give us
a Dada you know what I mean you know
what I'm saying yeah
so we're gonna get to the other oh hi
guys by the way we still know you're
there thank you so much for sticking
with us that was actually a lot of fun I
really like that I want to get back to
papyrus and uh and Undine back and snow
dude we just got to find out the best
way was this way yeah it was this way
okay so this way
maybe if I maybe if I wasn't mean dinky
that that big squid maybe that would
have given me a ride the guy who doesn't
like it doesn't like that you can't move
this block I'm pretty wimpy like just to
be perfectly honest okay we call the but
this is where L deposit oh he does it
for every single area you're in it's
important to respect our puzzling groups
yeah why do we have but Undine don't you
like tradition I worked in an office
pushing blocks for a month my respect
for block puzzles was depleted by
corporate life what you threw away my
dream life the life of a simple salary
man commuting every day on a train full
of spikes that's how it works okay oh
the dialogue for every single like area
oh my god wasn't this room the best like
when I decided to not do that boring
monologue and then when totally
off-the-cuff but when I almost killed
you with Spears when I almost killed you
with more Spears oh man I should have
taken photos
think about how cute a little scrapbook
would be ah now I want a scrapbook of my
fight too
let's start a photo company for boss box
one week later sample glossies in the
mail memories oh they do they kept I'll
look for every single frame that's crazy
unless it's not every single threat
maybe it's not oh wall I called when we
get lost or so welcome to hot land hot
land because I kept saying hot town hot
town
wait Suns was here he was nobody wasn't
on the way back remember he was asleep
that's right and then he left
maybe yeah what that wasn't there before
I remember the water below kick kick
kick hey I was thirsty so I came over
from waterfall to get a drink okay water
are you just carrying that around to
look sophisticated cuz it's not working
yeah okay alright then the water
evaporated from the heat the cup every
all righty then seeing such a strange
laboratory in a place like this filled
with determination
hello sorry undyne like told us there
was totally human in this area so like
that's Royal Guards are blinding out of
the elevators for now yeah even in the
elevators aren't working anyway we'll do
our best
miss undead oyster maybe you should call
to Paris yeah yeah what whoa guards are
blocking the way then I'll tell them to
well nothing I guess
I already told them to seek out and
destroy and I can't just tell them I've
changed my why not I thought we were
friends really cool Francie
Alfie's showed me these animations about
so I can learn their weaknesses is it
porn and one of them is about this human
that is it porn it sounds like well
suffice to say they can control people's
minds surprised I know your kind sit in
power anyway I told my crew that if I
ever defended a human I must be under
some kind of mind control and to get
disregard to everything that I tell them
oh so sorry but my hands are tired by
the way that animation is really good oh
okay alright okay
well alright we got a good down then
keep exploring oh do you take us back to
trololol I am the river man or am i the
river woman it doesn't really matter how
dare you assume my gender I would love I
love to ride in my boat would you care
to join me right in the boat just take
us back hell yeah
yeah now we can go this night we knew it
we're geniuses
then we're off Shalala okay you're nice
nice add patience squat along I can't
take credit for that that is from that's
probably the really bad long eat a
mushroom every day no no thank you him
why then I know you're listening to me
was I mean what does that mean what does
that mean River man woman what does it
mean
oh that's where that egg was come again
sometime
anyway it's like it was like a magician
on the carpet I've never played the game
so I've never I have no idea what it
actually was but he's like when you flew
off in the guards League squad along
with her off and then on youtube poop
squad along we're here and then like you
shut up no it doesn't make it into
anybody if anyone see that youtube poop
they know what I'm talking about but
I've gotta get the back door down so
no-one ignore me
no one ignoring me hello hi kids
oh no is the other way should we go to
wonder sands is that well what I'll do
is I'll hit the I'll hit here and then
I'll take the tunnel and go filter all
the way back through the town
hey punk what's up achoo
papyrus how can you stand this code I
have no skin so why don't we stand and
grow bees instead it's too good because
I hate Greece but you don't know but I
have standards he sure does
I'm so glad you and I'm kind of friends
now you two go together like pasta and
burning okay if it sounds newsroom signs
signs signs
damn it sons why does he have the magic
flames shooting out there is there like
nothing no reason to be here hello
that's not my house this is my clone
tool shed do you call it your cool shed
no that's why we're friends Undine you
enrich my life with shed based puns
yes the only one I've ever made dude
already then you need to be honest why
cuz I've done all the time
no we did wait over here for these puns
is there any other reason that we need
to be over here everything seems the
same yeah everything seems absolutely
the same I don't know if there's
actually anything here that's new
no songs in there
well I mean do you think we should dig
around here should we keep moving this
story because we haven't made a lot of
progress yeah you see that all right
almost halfway through are we the game
no how would I know that I've never
believed where I met the stream for
today we got an hour and 10 minutes left
whoa whoa squad along
Timmy village what the room before the
darkening lantern room well I knew that
does he just drop hints everywhere I
said what he does cat food
yes that's a cat boat I would have
thought that you would have seen some
cat boats in your die but you're
obviously Hill informed about the cat
boat status oh that's the lab they were
talking about why is there a spotlight
on me hello oh oh the camera sees your
face uh-huh sooo dark to see near the
walls too dark to see near the walls
that's a bag of either dog or cat food
oh hello how do you own a bur wha no
oh my god do you want to do a voice here
oh my god
I didn't expect you to show up so soon I
haven't showered I'm barely dressed it's
all messy and oh I'm antsy
and hi I'm dr. office that's how this
goes royal scientist that's office but
I'm one of the bad guys not one of the
bad guys I'm observing journey through
my console your fights
your friendships everything I was
originally going to stop using my
knowledge I can easily guide you through
I know I'm right wave right to a scores
castle no problem a long time ago I made
a robot named Matata
Ted probably right originally I built
him to be an entertainment robot oh you
know like
yeah okay so I called it I was in the
midst of calling it happened I was gonna
call it I call it seems like an era or
something at the right same time but I
was calling it preemptively so I
consider that me called it okay we
called it we call it unless it's doing
the real thing where it's lagged off oh
yeah welcome beauties oh hey this could
literally be just my voice and creepy it
looks like a game show
- today's quiz show
oh boy I can already tell it's gonna be
a great show everyone give a big hand
for our wonderful contestant never
played before gorgeous
no problem it's simple there's only one
rule answer correctly or you die you
didn't call it outloud met a ton of tax
okey doke even Medicom have time oh
that's metal body renders him
invulnerable to attack that is ho let's
start with an easy one
what's the prize for answering correctly
cry screaming is against the rules
here's your terrific prize what's the
Kings full name let's see Oh ask or
dream or right answer enough about you
let's talk about this guy's literally me
there's a 100% me that is literally baby
what a robot's made of metal and magic
oh she's making a beat in her hands
that's cool too easy for you here's
another easy one for you two trains
train a and B simultaneously
departmentation ASAP season a and B are
two hundred two hundred fifty two men is
one hundred twenty seven twenty seven
today
eight how much longer till both bring
ties together indeed wonderful I'm
astounded bulbs don't count on your
victory okay
how many flies are in this jar be sure
to confirm that corrects you're so lucky
today let's play memory game what
monster is oh we know that's froggen yep
No why does she say indeed it's froggit
it's funny oh we should have trusted but
can you get this one
would you smoochie ghosts why is it
counting up
she's just going to stink-eye
keep counting great answer I love it
here's a simple how many letters in the
name see of course now it's easy for you
time to break out the big guns in the
dating simulation video game you kissing
cutie what does me we use favorites oh
she buys desert for all our friends
about his snail flavor and she's the
only one who adds it is one of my
favorite parts because games acts a very
powerful message about friendship and
alphys and offers a healthiest key part
helping our contestant are you whoa
you should've told me I'll ask a
question you'll be sure to know the
answer to
Cudas dr. alphas have a crush on
I wanna say it's us why would it be us
cuz I mean said watching us through the
screen the whole time
Jeremy was talking about with good call
good call Tyler good call doctor alphys
has a crush on who the unknowable you
see alkis believes there is someone out
there someone watching her someone she
thinks is cute and interesting
hello theoretical person dr. alphas
likes you
hi is it me it's me hi Alvis that's me I
think you're cute and interesting that's
me do you think she's cute and
interesting no good could she's mine
back off do it it's alfalfa plier how
the planets
too bad you are not real hey I've done
research about this there are alternate
you said the exact same thing about mew
mew kissy cutie but i'll give you the
benefit of the doubt
person if you're out there it's me all
the players real Paabo giving us a sign
right now that settles that with dr.
alphas helping you know has no dramatic
tension we can't go on like this but but
this was just the pilot episode next up
more drama more romance more bloodshed
until next time darlings oh okay
well that was certainly something I
figured it out okay good congratulation
well alrighty then
last question wasn't supposed to ask
that one okay fine wall is only a few
feet wide okay go through there wait a
few feet yeah phew generally means three
or more yeah how wide is this Pipo white
what are we talking about here it said
only a few feet wide if you can't fit
the tune there how wide is people this
is a good point but I don't think that's
it I don't think I'm three feet wide I
don't think this is a critical part of
this just okay
maybe if you need help I could you get
that phone it's ancient it doesn't even
have texting no oh wait a second please
phone here I upgraded it can do texting
items it's got a keychain I even signed
you up for the Underground's number one
social network nice now are officially
friends okay bye
alrighty then there's an elevator stairs
behind dimensional box
in another dimensional box oh yes yeah
oh yeah I'm gonna try to call so I call
I'm dying to see what they do about this
situation
she's known as doriel sir yeah hey tell
her I said hi okay and tell me how she's
doing and tell me if she needs anything
and wait no don't ask any of that
well no I think undyed hasn't Brussels
announcing maybe yes yeah that's the way
it goes
fridge filled with instant noodles and
soda take a package of noodles hell yeah
steal food you need some noodles oh heck
yeah let's take all of it
bag of dog food half full can I take
that to beat a figurine of a human
female with cat ears computer accessing
some kind of puzzle it's snowed in wait
there's no sounds like I walk through
the game or what get garbage can for the
cue that's a little weird the duty to
your location okay keep it that way
fool that fool fool that went the wrong
way
Saturday Freiburg Sandburg dusty all
these pixelated human history let's go
for it it's coming with a giant robot
fighting a beautiful princess who says
the strike is very accurate okay maybe
you are an alien that was the robot
finding him you know you have good
theories and then you have very bad
theories man they're all labeled human
history book a little human comic book
to scan each other
flinging energy whose essence reg is
very accurate I don't know it's a
gluttonous Android just running to
school with the choicest mouth it's like
his lay this trick is very accurate okay
Pingu Pingu and may see or do dirty lab
coat single clean dress all that side
dirty lab post one clean unused dress in
the press
in the closet okay
that's what you I guess their letter
from many monsters you frog it snowed
dog oh they're all unopened he's a lamp
with a pink fish on the lampshade no
light bulb incredible invention would
not nuisance bed folds into an extremely
easy to drop box Oh
problem for many tons TV premiere so
thank you for making their dreams come
true
screw him he deserves to die he sounds
like man there can only be one of me we
will not allow okay all right moving on
boy
just realize I didn't watch on down
fight the human oh that's too bad
well I know she's unbeatable I'll ask
her about it later
oh boy for now I got a call human guide
them no it's okay we go wow what is this
oh geez new mistake is nipping at our
trap yeah me too miss secondly believes
this lava can heal people
you're hurt oh no I am hurt I forgot ah
I'm hurt Oh God this bad ah if I get hit
I die Oh
Oh okay uh criticize you tell Vulcan
that its attacks are not helpful
oh I'm not helping okay cool
all right perfect
if I hug you in that burn me
oh that that was not good oh oh oh no oh
my god oh my god can I go now please
I gotta go back and save I forgot I
didn't say oh there's a boy like right
up there everyone's yelling at me but
you know just to play it safe I don't
wanna risk cuz I didn't say that whole
time and if I die it's gonna be bad that
was close oh I'm so close to death
Oh cuz I don't think I've upgraded my
armor and like ages oh man scared by it
we need to buy it that's what I just
said
thanks for reiterating my point there
I'm going back to the other way on the
on the flute it's getting a little out
of control I need a haircut okay
gonna call them in a minute okay it's
growing
wise Oh what is that
Justin debate gets in the way you're
playing no no do you know what too soon
today means it's not sisindri
that's just way I pronounce it cuz I'm
an idiot no okay soon dad a means it
means in Japanese culture it's a girl
that is like oh you're like I don't it's
not I don't it's not because I like you
or anything but you look good today man
don't get any wrong ideas about it you
know that said sure come on I'm playing
general like if a girl like pretended to
not like you and was me Helga
Helga in the Hey Arnold okay perfect
example okay 100% a perfect example yeah
so I don't know what sin did plan to
dead flame to submit a plane it's a
twosome to the plane all right not on
purpose
not yet seems mean but does it secretly
like you know way why would I like you I
could have just let it explain itself
you know I didn't actually have to
explain it because just explain this on
yes torture did shakes is no dismissive
- hey tell too soon to the plane hey
baby nice ass great ass you could
probably kick like a horse with that ass
Eddie
accidentally bumps you into twig
approach human oh oh oh that's healings
I could have healed
oh it's blushing it's budging not yet
hey we're gonna flirt
nice nice
cats nice - that's it
you sicko literally would have say it
was another guy that I got bad I didn't
write the damn thing all right what else
you got
so you like it's taste in movies and ho
nice tats you sicko where's that sick
come on now
this is bunch of oh boy
I'm in trouble ninety-two approach again
your diamond to the yard
oh you just had to get enough of them to
win they weren't heels okay goodbye
just turned into a normal plane for some
reason okay I'm being carried we still
on okay then where are we going
I hear using the phone I don't want to
do this on now oh my god I've had my
claw for the last digit for five minutes
I'm good I'm just gonna do it I'm just
gonna call oh that's gonna be the phone
call pyro nice dismiss you mischievous
monster is never warm enough hot enough
for ya know I what do I do
Oh bother oh okay let's crank up the
thermostat fire of the kids to the
excited
hot hot hotter hi yeah I thought these
whoo okay what was I supposed to do
there
they were just saved two thing yeah cuz
I want you to fire summer is a hurry
must be a secret to that maybe Hey
click what was going to surrender before
you interview hi
blue lasers I mean Alfie's here hi the
blue lasers won't hurt you if you don't
move orange ones um you have to be
moving and
okay so I need to constantly be moving
videos that's why I heard me sometimes
but not always which was confusing oh my
god dude
gods Evan took like that since Undine
called me to ask about the weather
there's no weather Danny what did she
call me
oh come on - switch yeah okay so dad
those deactivated here oh my god I
forgot to tell them where to god oh my
god keep picking me right now - photo of
the garbage chips are you trying to
hoard your chips for yourself with the
tips or anything fine
stick with the cheese it's the way to
work is blocked and I have to catch
mettaton shell on that phone the special
effects were amazing - they're bad he
was going to look real I've got a radius
medicine
yeah he's the most fabulous guy on the
other grabbing man the same Club
probably at least two no three dozen
members
wonder if it would be unfunny by
explaining the puzzle
I would read it if I currently have the
boxes okay whoa okay
Oh
no you had it
you shoot through No
yeah there you go
Wow love it I mean black you might be a
total nerd oh good job good job
totally impassable as the Royal Sciences
I have some tricks up my sleeve
I head back to the hotline laser
database and take it out a hawk in do
not head back I'm tired
finally someone turn off that laser now
we're free we can well I guess we'll
just keep standing here this green thing
or hanging out some toes is reactivated
yeah man this is huge rules the gotta
cancel okay
you gotta get those two on the left side
fields and down left
Hey oh all right then
oh I don't look good
- dr. singer walls kind of dark in there
isn't it
don't worry hacking the light system and
brighten it up give me a second it and
clear my throat of cheese's
oh yes welcome beauties to the
Underground's premier cooking show
cooking with killer robot pre-heat your
oven because we got a very special
recipe for you today we're going to be
making okay my lovely assistant here
will counter the ingredients everyone
give them a big hand
we'll need sugar milk and eggs go for it
sweetheart
you found the eggs good job
you found the milk good job if you found
the sugar good job
perfect
great job beautiful we've got all the
ingredients we need to bake the cake
milk sugar eggs oh my what a magnificent
moment how could I forget deadly lasers
the most important ingredient flour no
chainsaw Oh
a human's soul oh geez run ring hello
I'm kinda in the middle of something
here you make a substitution in the
recipe a substitution you mean use a
different non-human ingredient why
someone's vegan vegan
this is a brilliant idea alphys actually
I happen to have an option right here
right now MTT brand always convenient
human soul flavor substitutes a can of
which is just over on that counter over
there why don't you go get that darling
oh that's suspicious
oh that's very suspicious well that's
our business
well darling why don't you go get it
first
what's the matter not a can fan that's
too bad MTT brando uses only the
freshest artificial ingredients and
chemicals alrighty then still fiddling
with the microwave eh darling can't
blame you for being totally enamored
with an electronic box is yellow looks
like someone forgot to preheat it
what's the matter
Hey okay fine we'll go over to the right
fine it's obvious trap okay papi the way
our show runs on a strict schedule if
you can't get the can in the next one
minute we'll just have to go back to the
original plan
so better start climbing beautiful ring
fortunately I might have a plan features
you see that huge button that says jet
pack
watch this oh oh jeez there
you should have just enough fuel to
reach the top now get up
nice go for it man you got this you're
all over this oh my god nice good job
you're doing great
I can't believe he has that many eggs
who's got you're doing great you can go
in the middle of dude you totally could
go in the middle oh yeah this is I was
thinking that you were thinking that
those burger yeah that way you can make
it you can make it you can make it you
can make you can make you can make it
you think you can make me oh I'll get
you some day little Billy
whatever your little peep oh no my
recipe could definitely go for some NASA
people's
oh you're not gonna make it he oh my my
it seems you've bested me but only
because you're at that help of the
brilliant doctor Alfie's oh I loves to
think what would have happened to you
without her
well toodles but right by Madison oh yes
about the substitution haven't you ever
seen a cooking show before I already
pretty cake ahead of time so forget it
okay oh I was like it was we did we
really did it great job out there team
anyway let's keep heading forward okay
sounds good to me
who say vias definitely bad an ominous
structure looms in the distance you're
filled with determination nice ring yeah
that's the pour the source of all power
for the underground okay
it converts geothermal thermal energy
into magical electricity by any way okay
okay cool sounds good
Oh what do you what was that what did
you just do
how'd you break that no you can't do it
go up please select a location left
floor one or right floor - I think you
read left and right and you can't want
it - so that makes sense to your left
okay let's start with the first one that
don't hope for the best
okey-dokey then where the heck are we oh
oh you're at the entrance of the
laboratory okay that's good so you're
done there so that's just an easy way to
get back and get the snowden if you need
to so I'm assuming we're gonna have a
final battle with mettaton that would
give the ability to kill yourself whoa
dude all right across the bridge yeah
I'm afraid we can never come back from
this one
hey um he claimed has been remember my
name
okie-dokie heat wait what was it we
could go back he was a heat flaming or
over the heats whose heats flames man
heat flames man heats flames man Vulcan
toasty bun
love hog no on that guy's roof over that
you just do cleans it
yeah duck a past feat dog
it's short for hot yeah something that
was original voice you had for him nope
pretty good name close
now it's talking like Alfie's gotcha
wanna buy a hot dog yeah you gotta save
your money for college and spiders okay
okay that's a lot of gold
mm we would have been there for like a
minute
no that's good okay just keep moving
yeah
eat up crank up the thermostat Oh
feeling satisfied good yourself
oh oh oh my god go out cheese I didn't
even see them spawning in okay goodbye
why is it cuz it's heat waves down
nastily affinity to send a friend
request its napstablook spree that guy
who is Napster with the ghost no he's so
friendly so he saved our life because I
punched the dummy I would say yes
all right we'll accept it seems a farmer
yes stain different this is delightful
the big thing okay then
it was interesting to get that boat gave
us a clue about tenor village you've got
ten below the area before the lively
that's when I said about the coup then I
would have been legitimately curious
about our village it's kind of timing
dates you see the switches over there go
you don't have to press all three of
them within three seconds I'll try to
help you with the rhythm okay ah okay
now press the third one
Hey looks like you only needed impress -
that's funny that's funny guys that's
the last time I try to help with the
puzzle I sure can click so each time you
hit it it it rotates where of that skill
and back and then
also each head of it does it once
I gotta I gotta somehow but if you go
down back on the conveyor and then right
around this would be able to do not
touch that one hit that
that is true that that so we need to
have it pointing the correct direction
yeah no that's the way it was pointed
before we need to not hit the first bet
yeah so no we had it pointed the
opposite direction
no usually was that way
that's where oh no I just I wasn't
supposed to hit that that one again yeah
cuz I just Mac was supposed to do that
but yeah okay so now we could just hit
this one and then do it yeah oh no see
it's still there yeah yeah okay yeah
wait cuz no matter what those two don't
align so we have to somehow get on the
one below
okay
so
you need to be able to get down that's
right you go down down that's that's the
big skill right
maybe we've to go back and forth sound
care
back up back up again a person
because if I go up one edge
we're not beggars
right oh wait no no yeah we did yeah out
of sheer luck it's not weed that was all
me baby I mean we knew what we were
doing it's just was a matter of no no it
was me
you were lost like a sheep in the
darkness nice no face time slender man
time knowing the mouse might one day
hack the computerized safe and get the
cheese the fusion of determination
there's a piece of cheese inside this
computerized laser so if the lasers have
melted the edges of the cheese that
stepped into my garden to get it wounds
don't they get room you can use entire
choker
you move chitty-chitty to review new me
kiss eqd to is no to kissing your cutie
it's trash nearest us all right I feel
like we're approaching the final fight
with meta - hey you stop
oh hi we've like we've like received an
anonymous tip about a human wearing a
striped shirt they told us they were
wandering around hot land right now I
know it sounds scary huh well steak
chill will bring you someplace safe
okay no huh
what is it bro the shirt they're worried
like what about it does that put on that
apron yeah bro are you thinking what I'm
thinking bro bummer
this is like mega embarrassing it we
like actually totally have to kill you
and stuff Oh Oh another burger
what's perfect all right yeah Royal
Guard member was shining buzzed a bird
like DeMuth -
whoa oh wow that's a lot of attacking
okay so whisper whisper tell RG wanted
to be honest but these feelings
what oh oh my goodness gracious
oh holy jiminy Christmas I for instance
so he's standing girl
tell her to do your favorite secret oh
that's so sweet
oh I I'm going to die I'm gonna die so I
need a whisper to this one we didn't
check the second one
I'm sure ah geez of your spirit okay so
what if I clean the air made the first
time to touch our jewels your hands
simple like I think okay well I didn't
check so maybe was but I'm assuming
that's correct why I got Helsing so
clean your teeth it's cooling dirt
begins to wash away Oh like parachute
stuff
oh nice oh that's so nice
well keep cleaning it take it armor too
hot
oh nice much better the one looks
bothered by something yeah brothers
getting naked and then you have to keep
cleaning his brother
looking muscular Bongo hello oh Jesus oh
these missiles are going off target yay
sweat fortune to Tsar Murr so I gotta
keep Patty's chest like a muscular Bongo
wait as a mice is that supposed to be
something that I'm doing or am I
supposed to whisper too I mean in a
western town
Oh Noi Mosely military zoo favorite
secret dude
okay so maybe I got to do something to
the first grade because yeah whisper
yeah to be honest with Jules yeah that's
the stuff that's right okay that's never
[ __ ] I'm an idiot
whoa dude anymore not like this like ooh
- I like thank you bro oh I thought they
were a real brother cuz I guess oh so he
was enthralled by the muscular chest is
that the way you fight bro the way you
talk bro I love doing team attacks
I lost standing here with you bouncing
waving our weapons and sink - I like
want to stay like this forever
whoa
Micah Joel what was it - singing don't
blur dude oops
yeah bro do you wanna
it's a ice cream after this sure do you
wanna get some ice cream with you yeah
yeah yeah yeah brew can i pat your chest
like a bus okay now I kill them now I
kill them right here at their weakest
moment I mean that's how it works right
when they're actually good at once yeah
they'll die they'll die happy but I
don't like risking it cuz you can only
hit one and you only have four health no
on the other one probably be really
pissed and logic it's good logic all
right okay bye
lots of gold pretty good gold okay bye
now
please be a safe point oh I'm sure
there's a save point obviously how's the
here to do there must be a simple
top ten shows that make you forget to do
your freakin job I would have totally
thought you needed to avoid the steam
but was there save okay I'm back
don't worry my hacking skills have
gotten things God things covered Oh No
are you serious yes
good evening beauties and gentle
beauties this is medicine reporting live
from MTT news an interesting situation
is arisen in eastern London don't
question that way fortunately our
correspondent is out there reporting
live brave correspondent please find
something newsworthy to report our 10
wonderful viewers are waiting for you
I'm the correspondent yes basketballs a
blast isn't it darling
too bad you can't play with these balls
they're MTT brand fashion basketballs
for wearing mouth of blank you can't get
rich and famous like moi without
beautifying a few wars before this one
has gotta be good
oh my it's a completely nondescript
glass of water but anything can make a
great story with enough spin that movie
script how'd that get there it's a super
juicy sneak preview of my latest
guaranteed not to bomb film mettaton the
movie 28 starring Minutemen I've heard
that like the other films it consists
mostly of a single for our shot of rose
petals showering on my reclining body
that's not confirmed you wouldn't spoil
my movie for everyone with a promotional
story would you that was close you
almost gave me a bunch of free
advertisement okay maybe that that word
as per journalistic standards a death
force fields from intrigue Oh this video
game you found is dynamite though I
don't make an appearance in it until
three four yeah but I like that
appearing from the heavens like mana
slaking the audience's hunger for
gorgeous robots and it's addressed to
you darling
aren't you just bursting with excitement
what could be inside well no time like
the present
to find out report this what a
sensational opportunity for a story I
can see the headline now a dog exists
somewhere frankly I'm blown away
I always do love a good dog story pretty
much my entire nude videos is nothing
but dogs dog still exists this story
just keeps getting attention viewers our
correspondent who's found a dog frankly
that would get the cue audience awwws
that's right folks
the feel-good story of the year look at
its little ears tiny paws pull off a
tail wait a second that's not a tail
that's that's right that dog is a bomb
but don't panic you haven't even seen
the rest of the room yet ah it's all
bomb
oh my it seems everything in this area
is actually a bomb that presence of
armed Oh that basketballs a bomb even my
words are okay
bombs rave correspondent if you don't
defuse all of the bombs this big bomb
will blow you to smithereens in two
minutes then you won't be reporting live
any longer how terrible how disturbing
our nine viewers are going to love
watching this good luck darling
okay don't worry
I installed a bomb defusing program on
your phone poor dog
don't use the defuse option when the
bomb is in the defuse zone okay
now go get up okay no no what that's
that's not what I want I want to defuse
option I'm not fighting it knowing dog
defuse bomb Oh
oh yeah I got ya okay yeah dog of yous
got it nice thank you great job keep it
oh jeez that's me fast okay so I just
gotta remember
boink thanks man
all right no actually there's got to be
something good behind this all right
pretty good at this
dead-on bang on
child's play well done darling
you've deactivated all of the bombs if
you didn't deactivate then the Big Pun
would have exploded in two minutes now
it won't explode in two minutes instead
it'll explode in two seconds hug goodbye
darling
well that's not fair and I'm kind of a
dick
seems the bomb isn't going off that's
because while you were monologuing I
changed
oh no you deactivated the bomb with your
hacking skills yeah that's what I did
curses it seems I've been foiled again
curse you human curse you dr. ralphus
for helping so much but I don't curse my
eight wonderful viewers for tuning in
until next time darling Wow hey I know
it was kind of weird at first but I
really think I'm getting more more more
confident about guiding you don't worry
about the big bomb dumb robot I'll
protect you from him and really came
down to it just could just turn
nevermind later I think it's talking
yes she's talking about the game from
like a menaced and I'm pretty sure she
because we're show she had game
walkthroughs on her on her desk
yeah sure that was this game walkthrough
that might be the maker of this game or
something they're not that maker of the
game but like you know like she controls
she was like you have to press those two
two times it's like three the three
buttons of sequences look oh you only
had to prison two times yeah hello
I can't interact with this alright okay
what if what if office is actually the
the boss that's trying to take your soul
in the end and I'll be oh yeah
he's God to be you say don't worry okay
the king is a really nice guy I'm sure
you can talk to them and with your human
soul can you pass through the barriers
this is no worrying okay
just forget about it in smile okay don't
give me a safe what was that guy's name
flames heats he lame limbs man okay
oh I need to go back down that's what I
need to do so I need to go left floor
walk and then go back and save
just to be sure that everything that's
taking care seems such a beautiful
laboratory filled with determination why
was that other place called the bad
opinion yep
okay why anyway that is all the time we
have for our little live stream today
today so we are back huh weird on we
were all flippy-floppy than the camera
but now we're all nippy Naveed this is
fun is a fun game so we're gonna be back
next Thursday at a same time and up next
on YouTube primetime is Jeff Gillian his
main show so go check that out
I'll put a link down in the description
later but you can also go to youtube.com
slash primetime go there right now
that'll be pretty cool so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always we'll see you in the next dream
bye bye time bang your chest like a
muscular bond oh oh decent bang your
chest like a muscular bongo oh you don't
have any most
okay